hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
trouble in meinem film ich habe gerade
bei facebook gefragt was ihr sehen wollt
und da kamen ganz eindeutig hunger games
raus beziehungsweise nicht ganz
eindeutig aber es hat auf jeden fall
geführt und ich bin nun seit wirklich
ungelogen seit 540 minuten dabei in
server zu finden wo ich aufnehmen kann
ohne das mich entweder in cannes erkennt
das irgendwie ich nach ein paar minuten
sofort wieder sterbe was dann keinen
sinn ergibt oder irgendwas anderes
passiert ich bin noch auf solche
komischen zweifel games in usa ein joint
nur da machen die einfachen team von
fünf leuten und so deswegen hab ich
jetzt einfach gedacht die spiel ein
bisschen trouble in wein will tut mir
leid und zwar hatten wir um gespielt
sonst gern gemacht ein von sein hat mir
dann aus ein anzug angezogen finde ich
sehr geil dienst gehen und wir schon
seit ich habe hier ein anderes tech
speck drin das ist das event ein texte
packers in der beschreibung da habe ich
auch schon review zu aufgenommen wird
auch die tage in wann kommen und der
shader funktioniert mit diesem text pack
irgendwie was mich sehr gewundert hat
wartet mal
ich versuche also sagt beim jetzt nicht
allzu wohl eine kiste es hat zwar immer
noch ein bisschen aber naja ich hab euch
ja schon gesagt dass ich die shader
mittlerweile sich immer mehr damit
sympathisiere
und ich werde mir auch in der nächsten
zeit eine neue grafikkarte holen dass
ich zwar nicht unbedingt immer schneller
erholen kann und ich werde dann noch
bearbeiten aber so wie sie jetzt sind
sind die eigentlich ganz gut und das
coole ist warte ich noch mal kurz /
trader 521
und ach ja hierbei dieses sehr komische
ganz jungen alter weißen extra nicht
hinterherlaufen damit dann nehme ich
hier auf und dann laufen wir trotzdem
hinterher ist einfach bescheuert und
zwar werde ich mich jetzt eben schon
umbenennen
jammern
nein ich bin aus dem bett gefallen
wir gehen das
die picasso entfallen harmonisch heißt
wie wir das also das verstehe ich gerade
nicht
ich bin zwar damit einverstanden dass
ich jetzt irgendwie gestorben denn ich
hab ja so gar keine mehr bekommen dafür
dass hineingedeutet habe sehr ganz neues
aber was ist mit dem was überhaupt los
im rechteck store fehler muss nochmal
bearbeiten
nur wieso bin ich aus dem bett gefallen
das frage ich mich gerade oder lag das
war irgendwie so einem fall oder so ich
weiß nicht ob ich allgemein noch nicht
so oft gespielt
na ja dann würde ich sagen hey ich
einfach nur aufnahme hinten dran so und
da sind wir und überall auf mittlerweile
wirklich diese um gespielt skins rum
dass es eigentlich ganz geil dass ich
jetzt das kind zu verbreiten und ich
habe ja hiervon hängt dann habe ich auch
schon gesagt dass folge eigentlich und
nein ihr braucht jetzt nicht wieder die
ganze drum heulen dass ich ja mal die
ganzen dass ich einmal skins wechsel ja
ich weiss ich finde viele skins geil ich
hatte auch eine kurze zeit ins kind von
meinem kumpel martin der hatte ja zum
dinosaurier also sein cooleren
dinosaurier erzähle ich jetzt habe und
ich werde das immer mehr ab und zu
ändern und ich werde auch bald wieder
den villagers kinn haben denke ich weil
ich den villagers kind eigentlich auch
voll geil finde immer noch und weil ich
auch so mit der einzige bin der den
verwendet bzw der einzige der also damit
angefangen beziehungsweise dem skin
hatte altana so versteht was meine wenn
die kiste so ich habe schlecht ein
schwert dort heißt wir machen ein
bisschen randale der hinten übrigens
heute sind auch model und der um
gespielt oder lou place oder neuer job
oder wer sonst halt immer wenn wir dabei
ist die sind heute nicht dabei und zwar
ganz einfach weil es ist 14 14 wtf es
ist 14 uhr
oh mein gott ich bin so ein bisschen
erstaunt weil
sogar etliche sachen hin chillig ich
glaube er weiß also ich heiße nasri sky
hd das ist jetzt mein meine februar fakt
das war auch ein schweres spiel zu
bilden ich bin einfach der grösste
vollidioten es gibt online ich bin so
bescheuert egal trotz nur mit zehn mann
macht online ich habe man dann später
getötet worden hankammer vor die wand
malte vor dass irgendwann
andy habe ich den gar nicht gilt oder
habe ich erst nachher bekommen wieder
aus dem app gefallen ist ich weiß es
nicht
na ja ich liebe dieses texture pack und
damit dem shader und dann da sehen die
bäume auch wenn die im feld fest sind
sehen die bäume auch noch eigentlich
ganz geil aus und wo ich kann es mal
ganz kurz fans sie sich eigentlich auch
ganz gern los obwohl er habe ich mag das
nicht wenn die blätter in wie alle so
durchsichtig sind nicht lässig guckt
euch das mal an das ja okay eigentlich
geht das schon so gailer aus aber dann
gehen die framerate ein bisschen runter
übrigens ich nehme jetzt das ist das
erste mal dass ich mit dx tore aufnehmen
und ich kann euch dieses programm nur
empfehlen ich wetter zu beidem ein
tutorial machen danke an so einem typen
ich habe den namen von ihm vergessen der
shader gesendet wird mir das tutorial
gezeigt es ist alles das sind total
cooler typ und so ein anderer der ist
nämlich auch den namen vergessen wird
das texture pack gezeigt aber die
kombination ist einfach so derbe geil
das ist richtig hammer na ja ich würde
sagen 'ich packe noch eine aufnahme
unten dran und dort werde ich euch dann
erklären warum ich gerade so überrascht
war und warum ich höre feuerwerksraketen
wtf warum eine stimme aus ein bisschen
behindert ist auf windows erfuhren
deswegen komisch building
die kennen mich ich komme ganz gut auf
den server ab sofort wieder meinen namen
geändert hier wartet sieht man das sieht
man dass niemand den man mir gar nicht
so ihr seht dort unten links oder jetzt
unten rechts wird von unten nase hat
aber jetzt müsste nicht denken dass
jeder nasen scilla hd dass ich das jetzt
bin und jan haase hier ist ein richtig
geiler fußball spieler samir nasri
spielt bei frankreich und bei manchester
city
na ja ich wollte euch sagen warum ich so
müde beziehen wir sie so komisch drauf
bin gerade ganz einfache tatsache wie
ich hoffe ich krieche paar kisten ich
hoffe das hat jetzt auch nicht allzu
heftig wegen fancy graphics
nein die habe ich nicht gekriegt ja ja
ja nein ich will stein schwert
und zwar bin ich ich hab's nicht
irgendwo gepostet
aber ich brauche endlich mal bei twitter
wenn wenn ich irgendwie zeit da fertig
mache das nur kurz wieder auf falls
dagegen dass sie alles doch schon ein
bisschen flüssiger vonstatten
ex post ich immer wenn ich irgendwie
nicht irgendwie ich bleibe jetzt mal
nicht die trader
ich habe meine taktik so von craft hat
sich um genannt es ist nicht umbenannt
naja jedenfalls in meiner eltern seit
also heute wenn jetzt wieder wird es der
vierte diesen seit dem zweiten weg
umbenannt danke polder lp und die sind
halt an er nur ort wies das sonnen insel
und ich habe gesagt nee kein bock
mitzukommen das wetter das kein typ den
ich kenne weil ich habe es ja schon mal
mit ist erzählt das dorf zu wirklich so
leute sind die mit denen ich dann halt
was machen
so und deswegen fahre ich auch mal mit
news
dass die taktik
der detektiv gekillt ich habe mich gut
ich frage mich gerade warum da kein
anderer war von den ganzen leuten oh
warte ich verstehe mich erstmal hier
drin
eigentlich ich bin einfach eigentlich
beschützen die auch immer alle die in
detective naja ich jetzt mal ganz kurz
zu ende und zwar sind die aufgelöst und
ich bin halt mit gekommen und deswegen
bin ich hier und immer wenn ich alleine
zu hause bin
mehrere tage wenn man eltern
vernünftiges mass effect dann ist das
hier immer wie seine wg dann lade ich
übelst viele leute ein und also party
immer nicht macht nicht eine party wenn
ihr sturmfrei habt das ist total
bescheuert oder lautet dann fünf leute
einfällt dann kommen also das doppelte
kommt immer an den leuten die eingeladen
habt es gibt milliarden prozent ich
irgendwas kaputt zehn millionen leute
bezahlen nicht den eintritt und
irgendwer kotz sowieso und nachher alles
im arsch und die braut das hat dann
nichts gebracht diese partie aus als ihr
wenn ihr glück habt ihr geld auch noch
eingenommen aber ich okay ist nicht
konkret gut erkannt homberg uschi
pilsbar korn ja genau
ja genau jedenfalls bin ich dann halt
nicht hin gekommen und dann was wir
öfters einmal machen es einfach uns dann
mit chillen fifa spielen so fünf sechs
leute und da war dann halt das einsame
treffer drauf mojang wanka auf dem
server von dem beispiel auch nur
heimlich alle getötet
und dann haben wir ein bisschen tiefer
gespielt und gestern im dritten sind um
20 uhr abends war eine schnapsidee um 19
uhr habe ich bei und marc halten die
gefragten vorbeikommen wollen et abend
also danach sei seine play sie
mitgebracht und ich habe hier einen
zweiten bildschirm und fernseher also
ich hab ihr pc zweiten bildschirm pc
entfernen sondern dem zweiten bildschirm
vom pc kann ohne play sie dran hängen
das ganze funktionale und funktionstest
kanal funktion abels poppenborg und dann
waren wir ungelogen bis 6 uhr morgens
wach und wir wollten nicht durch machen
weil ich noch schlafen wollten ihr wollt
um 4 uhr ins bett gehen und dann bis 12
uhr kennen und problem war einfach dass
wir die zeit vergessen haben dann haben
wir super gespielt und ich habe
mittlerweile 70.000 coins also aus 0 79
tausender sieht ihr seht ihr wie hier
wieder nur gezockt
der schlusssatz und extrem komisch
und ich bin überrascht weil der wecker
um 11 uhr gestellt was ich bei marks
vater wollte die um 12 uhr abholen und
wir haben einfach so derbe verbrennt und
das war danach irgendwie halb eins der
fall da stand eine halbe stunde vor der
tür
wir sind aufgewacht und euch dann denken
was passiert ist erst mal die schnauze
bekommen auf jeden fall eine vater nicht
so gut gelaunt und wir standard also
während verpennt acht der verpennten
sich als gar nicht gedacht jedenfalls
waren wir dann das waren dann um eine
weg und dann habe ich alles aufgeräumt
so matratzen flaschen usw habe jetzt
gerade auf nasri geboten übrigens 30.000
angebot und die menschen dass sich hier
die zeit ein bisschen bei springe bis
ich endlich weiß wer gewonnen hat weil
wenn später natürlich noch gewinnen dann
ist natürlich gut für mich auch noch
punkte
deswegen bleibe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen auf dem server
das ist der trader okay der wird wohl
keine chance am bogen gogo wer bist du
renata bahn
naja jedenfalls haben wir gestern halt
so viel scheiße macht einfach nur ganz
dieses punkt video da ungefähr zehn
milliarden mal angeguckt mit golo
erklärung nach was geht was hier ist
training experte für trending topics
neuer pop experte für training topix
rocket man war schon geil
so hatte man es ganz woanders allerdings
seien ernst kann man bitte spielen
na ja ich würde sagen ich berichte dass
jetzt einfach mal ab
das war's dann fließen wenn meine stimme
ist einfach so weil wir die ganze zeit
im forum geschrieben welcher stimmen
frei hat und wenn man tiefer spielt dann
rastet man schon hat man zu den dreien
bisschen auszurasten so dass der trader
obwohl wir uns einfach immer verfolgen
oder kommt der detective egal ist ob das
jetzt einfach mal
ich würde sagen danke fürs zuschauen
danke dass du immer noch dabei bis level
höher hat hat wenn du immer noch dabei
bist schreibt bitte creeper in die
kommentare
dann sehen wir dann da sind dann sehe
ich mittlerweile immer wie viele von den
leuten wirklich das video zu ende
geschaut haben
weil viele schreiben einfach your video
war geil und wenn dann wenn ich dann
sage ja schreibt man bitte creeper in
die kommentare
dann sehe ich alle die comparex schienen
haben haben es wirklich zu ende geschaut
würde mich mal interessieren vor allem
weil google analytics und so was alles
ist ja ganz billig so wartet der kampf
ist jetzt im moment vorbei alle der
titel zähle frei im kopf loslaufen noch
hinterher los mach ein foto von dem
schiff oder von der punkt von aa und
schiffe von foto wir können jetzt auf
einen screenshot gemacht oder ohne wind
keine affären
wann die sollen jetzt mal den trailer
darum bringen wenig der trader wäre ich
würd mich einfach stellen
ich meine keine chance wir finden auch
darin sind sie kann ich auch noch
fotografieren was geht
und ich glaube ich angst und sie direkt
vor dem stehe
und wisst ihr was für meine freunde ich
quatsche gamal viel zu viel
ich würde einfach sagen wenn ich das
video gefallen hat bewertet dass bitte
mit einem daumen hoch und wenn es euch
nicht gefallen hat dann bewertet es auch
einfach mit einem daumen runter audi
instanz am gewonnen cool ist habe ich
auch endlich die zeit totgeschlagen
dann würde ich sagen wir sehen uns in
der nächsten folge top level wieder
nicht vergessen trip in die kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr jetzt immer noch
dabei sein und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal zu gast